joining us here on this show former
coach of the washington
uh football team as it is currently
known and fresh off of the staff of the
jacksonville jaguars jay gruden how are
you jay
rick i'm doing good how you doing i am
doing fine uh what did you think of
super bowl 55 how did that game hit you
jay well i was uh it was still fun to
watch you know it's fun to watch the
team i think todd bowles did a great job
with that buccaneer defense
obviously uh just put the clamps down on
patrick mahomes the pressure was too
great for him to get anything going and
obviously tom brady did his normal time
radius fishing game getting the ball
spread around and making big plays and
winning another one so what did uh
what did bowles do best you can tell
that was so successful in a manner that
so few teams have been able to
pull off with mahomes what was it i
think you've kept consistent pressure on
them
you know really i think the lack of you
know the injury the fishery i think hurt
a little bit you'd feel
every time patrick went back to pass or
somebody come and slip free not
and not free because it was an unblocked
player in a blitz just free because
the defense was coming after him you
know barrett and pierre paul and b today
i mean these guys were coming
and uh that's off to the effort that
they played with able to sustain that
for
uh the entire football game you just
felt like every time was a drop back
pass
he had to abort mission and try to make
something happen and
uh it was great in the speed of the
defense lavonte david um
you guys did great in coverage and uh it
was just a masterpiece by the defense so
i mean
the fact that fischer was out and
obviously schwartz was out we knew that
there would be some sort of piecing
together or this offensive line
uh but then you look at the film and the
numbers that come off of everything and
you could see over
90 percent of the time just five-man
protection from homes you surprised that
there wasn't some sort of a half-time
change on that front or there was just
five-man protection
for their cubies yeah a little bit you
know i think they could have had a
little bit of success maybe chipping out
but you don't want travis kelsey to be
in protection and shipping
he's got to get out of the pattern you
know maybe a running back shipping every
now and then
uh but they've had so much success doing
what they do they the chiefs do what
they do
and they let patrick holmes go back
there and they'll make some people miss
and uh uh make the big plays with
tyrique hill and obviously kelsey
harden and those guys are great players
um
but yeah i think uh some shipping and
some help would have been beneficial
towards the end of the game
jay gruden here on the rich eisen show
and then the buccaneers offense
i mean you you've obviously been so uh
attuned to that side of the ball
well wherever you have been uh hc or oc
um is it it's not like a switch that can
be flipped but i mean the first 12 weeks
was just
so much um i guess inconsistency
and then from week 12 on they just
kicked into a whole different gear did
you see anything um
or notice anything obviously you had
your own house to take care of but how
how does that work i guess just in
general then
how how sometimes i think uh consistency
helps you know i think
when you have the same players playing
from week one to week 16
you can grow with the system and get
better and fortunately for the
buccaneers they didn't have a lot of
injury you know they're all from the
line stayed intact
you know god when mike evans they stayed
intact for the most part
you know i get antonio brown late but
tom had some good relations with him
obviously you know jones got hurt a
little bit but they had fournette
um so they were pretty consistent with
the players that they had cronk
obviously stayed
healthy so they're able to grow as a
unit and left which is able to get to
know tom what he likes and tom was able
to get
to know left switch and they were to put
piece it all together
come with a plan that everybody liked
were comfortable with and then they had
some emerging stars guys make plays and
uh and they they peaked at the right
time well obviously you also
you know from your time as being an
offensive assistant in in tampa
um what do you think that means to that
city that they got to do it again and
that brady's there i mean holy crap
uh jay it's insane that it actually
happened you know that's exciting it's
exciting for uh
city of tampa that's for sure you know
we didn't leave on great
uh we didn't we got green accord there
they fired john and they fired my
brother fired my brother by myself so
yeah we're kind of rooting for the chief
a little bit
there you go okay all right i gotta tell
the truth right there i mean heck i'd be
lying if i saw a room for the bucks
but uh you know i was hoping for andy
reid to win another one but uh you know
it's great for the city of tampa my mom
and dad still live there we love the
city of tampa that's for sure
okay so city of tampa we can separate
from the organization is what you're
saying
exactly that's a big difference
i was rooting for the double raise in
the lightning does that count yes it
does
yes it does i i you know you're you're
almost full dick vitale
basically that's what you're saying you
know what i mean like you're almost full
deck eve
rooting for everything in tampa but uh
see now that's the sort of
uh honesty that uh that is uh refreshing
and certainly can be brought to bear
being part of uh the media is that
your next step jay gruden is that what
you'd like to do hit the meeting i
wouldn't mind doing that yeah i think uh
i like to stay involved you know i love
the game i love talking about the game i
feel like there's something i can offer
that's for sure
uh but you know it's about to get a job
you know a lot of these
media jobs they seem like they're easy
from the couch until you actually get
there in front of the cameras or you get
there and you're calling a game i know
there's a lot of work i have to do a lot
of preparation that takes place but uh
definitely want to be involved one way
or another yeah i mean it it is
something that you know a lot of people
who
play and certainly coach think that you
know you do have a ton of knowledge but
there is some some sort of
uh way to communicate and clearly you
know uh your brother
very successful at it and you've got the
same cadence
and if you bring that sort of same uh
honesty to the equation
i mean that that that's one way to do it
um so
while we're on the subject of maybe
truth serum um
i'd like to ask you uh a couple
questions about your tenure
in in washington um dwayne haskins was
he
your uh first choice for quarterback
that year jeff we had a quarterback in
house and obviously alex has come up an
injury we weren't sure he's going to
play
right 99 sure he was going to play
the year after his injury up they were
clear there but we did pick up case
keenum we had colt mccoy coming back so
we did have a plan
uh to take care of alex for a year until
he did get back um
that being said we had other needs on
our defense and offense obviously and
quarterback wasn't my first choice at 15
but uh you know when you're not the
owner and you're not the gm
then you have to live with decisions
that are made you just hope they're
good for the organization and you may
not agree with them but uh they are made
and you have to move forward now
look it's it's it's a dicey situation in
which
we're we're currently residing in this
question this line of questioning
because i understand that dwayne haskins
is just
he's a kid right and so he yeah it's not
like you're denigrating him
or he's bad or anything like that it's
just that when you're on the board
15 overall you have a a choice that you
want to make and it's it it's no
offense to haskins i understand but who
did you want to have
that time well there was some guys on
board obviously sweat was still there we
like sweat a lot
uh savage was still there the safety
nickel uh from maryland who we like
lighter starting from green bay
right now we needed some speed in the
secondary so there's some issues we just
stayed past
and then kept our pick in the second
round and third round then
then okay if we chose to go that route
instead we had to you know we took half
which is fine then we had to trade up
and uh take sweat so we lost some draft
capital but
you know a lot to be said about dwayne
dwayne has a lot of potential still i
believe
um we just would have rather gone a
different direction and maybe
hope that dwayne would have slipped
maybe second or third round right so how
difficult
is it to coach somebody that uh was
drafted by
forces other than your own jay well
awesome
he needed a quarterback uh rich that for
sure so it was going to be somebody
um casey was on a one-year deal colt
mccoy is coming back from a broken leg
we didn't know if he was going to be the
same cult
so we had to get a quarterback uh the
other question the other thing is we had
to win right away
you know i mean so if you're drafting
guys for potential
i don't have time for their potential to
grow i don't have five or six years
for dwayne have to develop you know i
gotta win now and coaches that's the big
issue with coaches nowadays
is our our contract maybe three four
years but you really have a year if you
don't win right away you're gone
so you drop the guy that can develop
five or six years from now for who
you're not developing for me it's gonna
be for somebody else
and that's kind of the uh reason why we
want to go different directions somebody
can help our team right away
jay gruden here uh on the rich eisen
show
give me a good story growing up with
your brother jake what do you got for me
oh
yeah i'm sure i know i know when you ask
something like that of
somebody about a brother obviously
you've got decades of stories but
growing up gruden you got a good story
about growing up gruden you ain't what
was this
just you know he gets very upset when i
tell somebody story so i'm sorry john
but
you know he was very impatient you know
you know i'd sit in front of tv and we'd
watch tv
he's sitting behind me and if i had an
itch on my leg or something i'd scratch
it and
he'd sit on he spit on me and say sit
still dog boy
you know just things like that i took a
beating when i was a kid rich it was
tough
but he's a great brother of course but
it's just
got the uh opportunities in the nfl and
i would never go without them and
obviously head coaching job you know
learned a lot from them but growing up
is not always easy
so did you share a room did you guys
share a room or no just oh no we were
we didn't have a very big house but we
were close okay you know
look my two boys share a room right now
and we hear them talking till like 11
o'clock and we're telling them you can
keep shot
you know quiet down keep whatever so but
brothers you share a room i mean that's
that's something that's really you know
bonding
so your brother would uh he'd give you
crap pretty much how much older is he
yeah
he's three years older than me yeah
three years older my other brother three
years older than himself
and those two are exact opposites so
they fought every day and i always just
try to keep peace i want to play nurse
basketball and meet football and stuff
like that
usually i just break up fights every day
what do you mean you brought so your
your oldest brother is different from
than john so though they used to fight
all the time that's what you're saying
yeah
pretty much it was uh quite the eventful
afternoon at the greedon household
okay all right and and i guess one one
last thing about your brother if you
don't mind the
the the rumor is he can't stand at
quarterbacks any of his quarterbacks
he's always looking for another one
that's true i think he really likes
derrick in fact i've never heard him say
a negative thing about derek and what
they did offensively this year was
really impressive in my mind and i know
he doesn't like me talking about the
raiders and all that stuff but uh
i was impressed with every time i put on
a raider film and watching derek in that
offense i thought they were very he was
very good i thought he was dynamite i
mean look
you could say there were two cor look
week 17 forget about
you could say there were two
quarterbacks that beat the chiefs this
year tom brady and derek carr those
that's that's a fact you know so and
i'm just talking about all the time in
his career you know i i had rich gannon
on
i asked him the same question and uh i'm
like is
i asked him actually is it true you're
the only quarterback john gruden's ever
liked
and he laughed he goes i don't even know
if that's true about him
yeah probably not well
yeah i mean he got his first gig at san
francisco and
i believe he was with uh obviously joe
montana and he goes to green bay's
receiver coaches with brett favre
so you know the standard is pretty high
for him
right so if you could wave a wand what
job would you want
jay i mean what do you want to do you
want to call games you want to be in a
studio do you have any preference what
would you like to do
you know what i'd like to call games i
think i think uh
you know i i could offer something quite
uh entertaining maybe
you know we'll see i just got it i gotta
give it a try though i need a lot of
practice a lot of work the calling games
would be great in studio because i want
to talk about the game and be part of
the game so
i'm sitting around here in my house
right now and playing at beach is a
great day but
i'm saying i'm looking out the window i
don't know what to do what would you
think
i mean we you know and that's why i
appreciate you calling into the show uh
you know so normally you'll be going
tomorrow too the next day
thursdays with jay i mean we got that we
could we could work that thing going
all right look i mean so and and uh
you know obviously you you know you
created a little bit of a stir right
when you
talked about romo and his ability yeah i
didn't that wasn't my intent i mean i
was just i was just nothing around i
didn't know that would get picked up
like that
that's paparazzi yeah i don't know
that's
my fault sorry tony i was just joking
around but you said when you said that
he was right over
right only thirty percent of the time
jay is that what you said some along the
line
like that i don't want them enough to
really know i was nice making a point i
could guess
anybody could guess to play before it
happens thirty percent of the time right
hey
hey mahomes is going to drop back he's
going to look for kelsey or hill
how about that
[Laughter]
i mean he's not wrong that's not
complicated it's not wrong
it's very simple game when you think
about it you know yeah it's pretty
dead-on you're hired jay uh but i'm not
in charge you're not
i'm not in charge but if uh hey look if
there's anything i could do to help you
know
uh uh um i i'd love to do it i
appreciate it
all right you just get ready for the
next four years there you go you're
going to run four-year decisions
jay i am gonna do it um you know there's
no combine but we just announced
today as a matter of fact that it's
gonna be uh sort of reimagined in a way
i'm gonna still run but other people
don't have to run they could do anything
with a 40 just run the 40
40 steps or do 40 errands for somebody
in need or
run 40 you know 4.0 miles not saying
someone doing 40 miles but
i'm going to run i'm going to run a
straight line i'm going to run like the
win you know
great cause i mean thanks just great
effort it's awesome
effort it is i do give good effort the
problem is it just doesn't show up in
the stat sheet
that's my when you lose a lot of players
you're playing with second and third
string players a lot of times and they
give good effort
it doesn't usually show up in the win
loss column either rick so i understand
that
okay jay i appreciate that thanks for
the call you take care of yourself
let's do it again let's do it again soon
you got that's jay gruden everybody
right here in the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here